[Music]
and BJ train news [ __ ] trimmed or bj
j bj r pj j no I can't hear I didn't
hear the titles at BJ or BJJ we'll find
out
CJ BJ thank you submitted by Georgia
from Adelaide that's in Australia a man
received a criminal conviction after
getting a surprise [ __ ] on the train
why this is wrong seriously refused
[ __ ] that people offer it to you on
the train I would hope so you don't know
what if it was a surprise [ __ ] how is
he to blame ya it's like what if he was
wearing those basketball shorts that are
really easy to drop down
thank you was like it only takes two
seconds that's one thing nobody talks
about this that was one or what yeah
this scene in like nymphomaniac have you
seen that film no [ __ ] for our [ __ ]
film won't Shia LaBeouf like really
[ __ ] that girl like 17 times like it's
I mean it's great but there's like the
scene with these like girls I don't and
the fueler starts blowing him and then
[ __ ] come right in your mouth and you
see it yeah in the sense Shia LaBeouf
this is a Shia LaBeouf film
oh he's not this is the film of Shia
LaBeouf sent in a sex tape of his as an
audition so but that wasn't his scene
that's crazy
how shallow buff still has to send an
audition tape all actors do you know
Will Smith for Django he didn't get it
unless they're making a film for that
person with that person in mind you
still have to audition yeah crazy but
they were like moody and then they just
go like the people writing the film are
like I want this person well there's a
lot of those yeah cuz that's when they
have their own production company and
they just like like Johnny Depp it where
it's like whatever he wants he just but
let's say it's like a director like
Scorsese you're gonna [ __ ] audition
for that role but if it's like a random
script then they're gonna look for a
start attached to it yeah I gotcha
so this man from Australia he is named
ashame this is what you gonna give us
your Australian accent please - it's his
boy yes I love your axes your axes are
the best material to use how'd you do an
accident last time when you read
something it was amazing can you say
country chatter and
really that's a reference to take your
party so let's say that video safe foam
see now that's what I call a surprise
[ __ ] Oh see that go I could only make
it some country that's why my Australian
accent we don't know just do it we just
want to do it yeah that's what I call a
surprise border because Austrians always
say now that's what I call some yeah no
that's what I call no no no that's what
I call a surprise [ __ ] I can do that
English phone in Australian accent we
got a country cheddar or whatever is
that they wrote that sentence the sound
country and I couldn't get out of the
country I'd say no no okay this guy here
Mel babe here's another photo change
give you the full visual all right and
he was on a train a commuter train
similar to this and he says that when he
was there he there was this woman move
in the morning to Bowie early bird gets
the worm yeah yeah yeah told me that he
was in the movie transponding - I would
believe you
oh yeah but he says that looks like it
yeah just play he's about to climb into
the [ __ ] yeah he describes the woman
who had a mad body on the train it was
mad bro you're just [ __ ] grab her ass
no you just grab the woman with the mad
body I described oh describe this great
I can't reenact said I'm horny will you
[ __ ] me a pretty minute Zynga's al what
is with these new things going on right
now thing is al all right you're turning
the Jo just a little bit right close to
that that's just weird hearing somebody
100 million dollar lottery you like that
that happens I guess but not to me I
just want to hear big under the noise
that's why this say something crazy
right now why would a wall but a big
block or the whistle man where's the
whistle liner he just says random ass
we've witnessed something like this yes
a public blowed up yes Oh Texas they
were like and then what happened when he
came I was too busy dancing downstairs
was the come noise impressive situation
so it was a two-story club we were
upstairs and there's like this like a
supply room that were next to so we're
just talking doing whatever and then
this chick who's [ __ ] plastered walks
up the stairs and she's like where's the
bathroom a half the page she's right
this really short dress or whatever so
then she just kept banging on the supply
room thinking it was a bathroom she's
like [ __ ] I have to be at the P or
whatever and then a dude just like tries
to spit game at her like I just see him
trying to talk to her and stuff so then
I'm like whatever and then I looked and
there like macking right oh my god and
then we looked the second time or I
looked this our third time and then
she's like he's against the wall her
heads here she's just giving him head
and I was like what we did she have to
pee man she starts peeing on the ground
right look she's giving him a [ __ ]
like on the [ __ ] dance floor well
that we were at the club
the hot club you wanna give the name
give him a little shout out it was on
6th Street that Club is so I could shut
them down where is the second where
yeah that's not to code go upstairs of
that club yes that makes for the supply
room getting wild it no I'm saying you
don't have to go all the way to Austin
because from where Casey and I live we
have a balcony and it overlooks a
parking lot and sometimes and late at
night Casey and I will go out there just
hang out and then we'll look at these
cars I guess I feel like this is a
couple and they're probably same
worksheet I think they're cheating
because there's these two cars that come
in always on the same day I'm around the
same time and then they park right next
to each other and then the girl goes
into the guys car cuz he has like an SUV
and then that car is just bouncing dude
what were we watching a movie we're like
we had just up the movie theater or
something and we were all congregating
the way that we do next to the SUV and
then that we're like right next and it
started like bouncing up and down
good for them it sounds so familiar and
they were like right next to us and they
didn't even give a [ __ ] that we were
right next to their car they were just
haven't said hey does sound familiar but
I reminds me of another time when I was
alone and I was in similar it was a
movie theater parking lot but there was
other restaurants and I was going to a
restaurant and I see an SUV just [ __ ]
bouncing or they've been great music you
don't know yeah yeah they were just
bouncing of the music man come on now
and then the window or at least the one
that I remember the windows got all
foggy and [ __ ] it is smell like sex I
was in closing the [ __ ] Titanic did
it make you guys horny
[ __ ] a little bit just like mmm okay
good then now we're just used to it
we're like all their back end oh they
thought oh the first one was a little
horny yeah about eight times in it's
like they kind of want to see this after
it's like mmm you guys do the same thing
get a room it doesn't turn us on anymore
yeah yeah so back to the story so she
could shake harder than you
Shane was saying that the woman was
pretty horny and ready to go yeah but he
declined to have sex with her what a
gentleman but then that's when the woman
started masturbating
hany couldn't resist she asked if she
could give him a [ __ ]
we just sounds so fake by the way he was
like all right so then he let her do
that
by the time the train pulled into the
station there were security people there
waiting for them and there's no mention
exactly what happened to the girl but
this dude got in trouble and then
they're saying that when the security
people went into the train that they
thought he peed on himself but he says
no that semen baby that's bit no it's
actually coca-cola that he poured from a
bottle to rinse his dick on cuz he she
didn't he didn't know where she came no
I will say this though that I think that
he should get an award because he denied
her multiple times but when the [ __ ]
offer came I mean come on can't we
fought the guy no he said no no wait did
he get in trouble he did yeah but how
come she's not in trouble we should
begin with the key to the [ __ ] City
ya know why don't we just look at the
surveillance footage to see if he's
telling the truth so that's the thing
that's where why they're convicting him
for that's because they saw on the CCTV
that he was getting a [ __ ] oh but he
didn't say like didn't see the no like
stopping is that the funny thing is
she's not in trouble
where's the gender equality how many but
if I was eatin [ __ ] in the Train am I
gonna be in trouble probably you get off
scot-free I guess and this wall that's
whoever's receiving gets punished why
cuz his dick was exposed oh maybe that's
injustice no one else was in the
trainer's pretty good mouth yeah what's
wrong if she's doing it right but she
could have took a break and licked his
balls and that's when it would have been
food that
and she is almost she wasn't didn't take
a break and lick his balls yeah laughs
well then if he covered it with the hand
dad from the camera I know where the
cameras your coverage she was probably
going after the balls and the dick
landed on her face like a mill strip
always a good move I love how this guy's
story is like a perfect written porno
and it's not even like we're painting
the porno because we're so horny yeah a
none fault I feel like this is not true
though especially early in the morning
right it's like everyone's busy going to
work or whatever unless she likes didn't
sleep the night before because she's all
drunk that's the only case this is the
story that a 13 year old boy comes up
with in his room exactly he's like that
good woman's across woman's like I'm so
bad you just think that that could be
real important just like [ __ ] you up
right the kid it really makes you think
women are like that ya know it's like a
game operation man yeah in real life
it's a game of operation you just try
not to hit the metal while you get laid
try not to [ __ ] it up and turn her off
trying not to mess it up so that she's
like get the [ __ ] off of me
ah too late exactly yeah yeah so this
dude he was ordered to pay $700 finance
waste on a 12 month good behavior is not
bad for public head is a call public
head of these it was a scenario where he
came into a train and a random hot girl
said I'm gonna suck you off $700 is
worth it I think so that's really good
I'll take the fine cuz you told the
police to like I don't have to pay for
this yeah you know it's like when the
police pull over a Lamborghini who is
like going to 4d or something and
they're like that's pretty thick yes you
know we got a rich what you want to bet
the [ __ ] like police I chastise them
and act like off County one like this
[ __ ] dude 100% exactly oh I don't want
to take you to jail because I think you
deserve a medal he's like just cuz I
have to [ __ ] throw the book at you
doesn't mean I don't [ __ ] goddamn
respect you yeah
[Music]